Trump this go around at least intends to
be disciplined back to what you just
said there though it was not a rigged
election it was not a stolen election
you and your supporters lost more than
60 court cases on the election it's been
nearly two and a half years can you
publicly acknowledge that you did lose
the 2020 election okay let me just go on
have this been
the the first debate of 2020 had this
been a less disciplined campaign Trump
would have come in and gotten into a
shouting match with her going back and
forth he exhibited incredible restraint
there in fact he exhibited more
restraint than I just exhibited even
listening to what she had to say and
there was no question in my mind that
that was intentional and it's to convey
to the GOP base that this campaign is
going to be disciplined